Who's overthrowing governments?
I'm
not overthrowing governments.
I'm Mr. Beat.
Come on.
Y'all know me.
Still same old G. I ain't got time for
that.
But guess who has overthrown
governments? The United States
government.
Like
a lot. Regime change.
>> It's called regime change.
>> Is it in America's best interest to have
regime change in Iran?
>> And these wasteful regime change wars
>> President Trump now appearing to
entertain the idea of a regime change in
Iran with Trump posting online, "If the
current Iranian regime is unable to make
Iran great again, why wouldn't there be
a regime change?"
>> Oh, regime change? The United States
definitely knew her.
>> A coup, which is short for coup d'état,
is a sudden, forceful, and illegal
overthrow of a government. In this
video, let's look at every time the
United States did a coup or heavily
influenced a coup. How many times has
the United States overthrown a foreign
government?
>> Well, estimates range from 14 all the
way up to more than 100. According to my
own estimates, there have been 26.
At least 26 worth mentioning.
>> We have a bit of breaking news that has
just come in. Uh right now, the Iranian
state media is telling the people of
Iran that the Ayatollah has been killed.
Oh. Okay. According to my own estimates,
there have been 27. At least 27 worth
mentioning. Yeah. I know. That's a lot.
And these were the successful coups, not
the ones that failed. Because there are
so many, I'll keep it brief. For each
one, we'll break it up into three
periods: the Imperial expansion era, the
Cold War era, and the war on terrorism
era. ALL RIGHTY THEN, here's every time
the United States overthrew a foreign
government.
>> [cheering]
>> Oh, I should mention that we know of.
Here's every time the United States
overthrew a foreign government that we
know of.
>> [music]
>> So far.
During the imperialism expansion era,
the United States was a bit more brazen
with their imperialism. They didn't try
to hide it.
On January 17th, 1893, American and
European businessmen, with aid from the
United States military, overthrew Queen
Liliuokalani because her Hawaii first
policy basically threatened their
profits. Now, many don't realize the
United States didn't annex the islands
until more than 5 years later. In the
meantime, these business leaders just
started their own government there. As
you probably already know, Hawaii
eventually became a state, but the
overthrow of the Hawaiian kingdom
remains one of the most controversial
land grabs in American history. Over the
next several decades, the United States
went bananas
with the Banana Wars, a series of
American interventions in Central
America and islands in the Caribbean
Sea.
Hold on, I got to take this.
Hello.
No.
No. The name Banana Wars was popularized
by a historian named Lester Langley, who
wrote multiple books on American
intervention in Latin America, and he
called them that since many of these
interventions protected the United Fruit
Company, which made a lot of money off
of you guessed it, bananas.
In 1903, after Colombia wouldn't let the
United States build a canal through this
part of their territory, the United
States government encouraged Panamanian
rebels who lived in the area to declare
independence. The American president at
the time, Theodore Roosevelt, sent
warships to block Colombian troops from
stopping the revolt. And yep, after the
Panamanians gained independence, the new
country of Panama almost immediately
signed a favorable canal treaty with the
United States. Also in 1903,
the United States military supported a
coup by Manuel Bonilla, who was more
friendly to American business interests
like the aforementioned United Fruit
Company. Over the following years, the
American military would repeatedly
protect Bonilla from other attempted
coups. Ah, yes, Honduras, the original
banana republic.
Well, the United States originally
acquired Cuba after defeating another
imperial power, Spain, in the
Spanish-American War. At first, the
United States promised Cuba they'd have
independence. But then, the Americans
like just
wouldn't go away. Congress passed the
Platt Amendment, which said the United
States could intervene anytime it wanted
to against a government it did not
approve of, and it did just that. The
American military hung around Cuba until
1909.
Hey, speaking of 1909,
>> [music]
>> that year, the United States helped
overthrow President José Santos Zelaya
because he wanted to build a canal
across the country that competed with
the Panama Canal. And yeah, Zelaya
threatened American business interests.
American soldiers would support rebels
and ended up occupying the country on
and off for the next two decades.
>> [music]
>> I hate to break it to you, but every
time you go online, giant corporations
are stealing your personal data. And
then, data brokers are turning around
and selling your personal data to
anyone. Stuff like your address, your
phone number, even your political
beliefs and income level. Jeez, I hate
this crap. But you want to know one way
I fight back? By using DeleteMe.
DeleteMe proactively removes our home
address, phone numbers, and family
details from the internet. What I like
about DeleteMe is that it sends you
these personalized privacy reports
showing what they found, where they
found it, and what they deleted. I've
been using it for several years at this
point, and it's done a really good job
scrubbing my personal information from
all kinds of messed up sites out there.
Protect your personal information and
your family's personal information by
using DeleteMe. And get 20% off DeleteMe
consumer plans when you go to
joindeleteme.com/mrbeat
and use promo code mrbeat at checkout.
There's the QR code. That's
joindeleteme.com/mrbeat
using [music] code mrbeat. Thank you to
DeleteMe for sponsoring this video.
>> [music]
>> In 1913, Henry Lane Wilson, the US
ambassador to Mexico, and of no relation
to his boss, President Woodrow Wilson,
was very involved helping overthrow the
democratically elected president of
Mexico, Francisco Madero, who threatened
American oil interests. Well, Woodrow
Wilson would end up firing Henry Lane
Wilson, but he kept American forces
there anyway after continued instability
in the country over the next few years
in what became known as the Mexican
Revolution.
In 1915, American troops straight up
invaded and occupied Haiti after a mob
killed the country's president, Vilbrun
Sam. You see, American banks had lent a
lot of money to Haiti and they wanted
the American military to get that money
back. Hey, eyes down here, buddy.
Why are you staring at my forehead
anyway?
Pervert. The Americans disbanded Haiti's
army and controlled local politics in
the country for years.
>> [music]
>> On May 15th, 1916, American troops
landed in Haiti's neighbor to the east,
the Dominican Republic, to quote restore
order and then promptly ran the
government. Well, the real reason why
they were there was to protect an
American-owned sugarcane plantation.
Mhm.
They sidelined locally elected leaders
and installed American-friendly military
leaders in their place. The United
States military would occupy the
Dominican Republic until September 18th,
1924.
Hey Matt, Che Guevara here, fellow
content creator and Dominican who can
speak a little more in depth about this
topic, if you don't mind. Of course. Of
course. Thanks. The American military
had actually previously intervened in
the Dominican Republic in 1903 due to
the multiple rebellions. the United
States sent naval ships to protect
American property and interest in the
nation. They left shortly after, but
returned several times, such as in 1914,
when the Navy intervened to stop another
rebellion and oversee the next
elections. Fun fact, if you can call it
that, during this era, FDR was a key
architect of Wilson era naval
occupations in the Caribbean, setting up
the Dominican Constabulary and the
Herrera training schools that shaped the
military career of DR's longest-serving
dictator, Rafael [snorts]
Trujillo. I'll be back later, just like
the US, because the US comes back after
we stopped Trujillo.
Thanks, Shay. You can imagine this led
to a lot of anti-American sentiment
throughout Latin America. Well, props to
the American presidents Calvin Coolidge,
Herbert Hoover, and Franklin Roosevelt,
who mostly ended regime changes. Hoover
and FDR, in particular, implemented what
became known as the Good Neighbor
Policy, in which the United States
pledged to respect the sovereignty of
its neighbors and avoid direct military
intervention in Latin America. No more
military occupations. But then, World
War happened, and
during the Cold War, the United States
got more sneaky with the coups, and of
course, it was all in the name of
stopping the spread of communism.
Yeah, this is a little ripe.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Yeah, this one's a bit more famous. In
1953, after Iran's democratically
elected Prime Minister Mohammad
Mosaddegh nationalized
British-controlled oil, hurting American
companies, the Central Intelligence
Agency or CIA, as well as the MI6, the
British Secret Intelligence Service,
paid mobs, bribed officials, and spread
propaganda to cause chaos in the
country. Eventually, they aided in a
straight-up coup of Mosaddegh, replacing
him with Mohammad Reza Pahlavi, a king
more friendly to American business
interests. Pahlavi would rule with an
iron fist, and the people of Iran would
eventually revolt against him in what
became known as the Iranian Revolution,
which yep, led to the Iranian hostage
crisis.
Oh, yeah.
I have a video about that.
>> [music]
>> In 1954, Guatemala's president, Jacobo
Arbenz, began to take unused property
from the aforementioned United Fruit
Company to give it to poor farmers. In
response, the CIA aided rebels, ran
radio sci-ops, and bombed targets to
scare Arbenz into resigning. This was
actually the second time the United
States tried to overthrow their
government. The first time, 2 years
prior, was unsuccessful. A military
dictatorship followed, sparking decades
of civil war and mass killings.
>> [music]
>> In 1960, after the Congo gained
independence from Belgium, citizens
there elected Patrice Lumumba as their
prime minister. Well, the United States
feared he was a bit too friendly with
the Soviet Union, the CIA would help
Belgium assassinate him, and eventually
the dictator Mobutu Sese Seko took over
and terrorized the country for more than
30 years.
>> [music]
>> On May 30th, 1961, rebels ambushed and
assassinated Rafael Trujillo, the
dictator of the Dominican Republic. And
guess who supplied weapons to the people
who assassinated him? The CIA. The CIA,
always playing both sides. Hi, Che
again. Missed me? In 1963, the Dominican
Republic held elections and Juan Bosch
came into power as president of the
Dominican Republic as part of the
Dominican Revolutionary Party. This made
the conservatives on the island very
nervous. They saw Bosch taking land from
the rich landowners, creating a more
liberal and less secular constitution,
and allowing the Communist Party to
grow. Also, and most importantly,
limiting the power of the military. That
last one was the nail on the coffin for
Bosch's presidency. This led to the far
right of the Dominican Republic removing
Bosch in what they called a bloodless
coup, which replaced him with a military
junta. This led to a civil war in April
1965. Side note, my grandmother was born
in the Dominican Republic in 1933, 3
years into Trujillo's dictatorship. When
the civil war broke out and it seemed
like Bosch was going to come back into
power, she remembers having hope that
her country can have a real people's
revolution. However, my grandma's hopes,
like millions of others, were dashed
when the US [music] intervened in the
civil war and imposed a political
transition that first led to a
provisional president, Hector Garcia
Godoy, and then to the election of
Joaquin Balaguer, who was Trujillo's
vice president. Balaguer was president
of the Dominican Republic in 1988, when
I was [music] born in Dominican
Republic, and stopped being president in
1996. My first 8 years of life were
under a dictator that the US helped
install, just like the one my
grandmother lived under that the US
helped install. I am living proof that
the damage that the US has inflicted in
Latin America is not such ancient
history.
>> [music]
>> After Jose Maria Velasco Ibarra, the
president of Ecuador, got a little too
friendly with communist Cuba, the CIA
used propaganda, forged documents, and
straight-up bribery to overthrow him on
November 7th, 1961. Two years later,
anti-communist rebels within Ecuador
overthrew the next president, Carlos
Julio Arosemena Monroy, after he, too,
was a bit too friendly with Cuba.
>> [music]
>> There is growing evidence that the CIA
also helped plan and carry out the
overthrow of Abdul Karim Qasim, who was
then executed by firing squad on
February 9th, 1963. Qasim had been open
to closer ties to the Soviet Union and
communism.
>> [music]
>> After Brazil's president, João Goulart,
pushed for land reform and more worker
rights, this freaked out, you guessed
it, American business interests. In
early 1964, the United States provided
logistics and military aid to help
rebels overthrow Goulart and install a
harsh military dictatorship, which would
rule for the next 21 years.
>> [music]
>> The CIA helped Britain overthrow Cheddi
Jagan, the chief minister of what was
British Guiana at the time. After Jagan
got elected, he became a bit too cozy
with Marxism and the Soviet Union.
After Bolivia's president, Juan José
Torres, became friendly with Cuba and
nationalized the country's mines, the
CIA gave intelligence and other aid to
rebels. On August 21st, 1971, these
rebels ultimately overthrew Torres and
replaced him with Hugo Banzer, who, you
guessed it, also would rule Bolivia as a
brutal dictator for the next 7 years.
Although strangely later in the 1990s,
he'd return to power after Bolivians
elected him.
>> [music]
>> Well, Chileans elected a socialist named
Salvador Allende as their president.
After he nationalized the copper mines
and threatened American business
interests, the CIA caused chaos by
disrupting the economy and giving
millions of dollars to rebels for them
to conduct military strikes. On
September 11th, 1973, Chilean military
rebels bombed the palace and killed
Allende. Augusto Pinochet took over as a
brutal dictator and would routinely
torture and disappear citizens over the
next 17 years. Yeah, um
I think these are starting to sound
redundant.
On October 25th, 1983, the United States
military, along with a coalition of six
different Caribbean countries,
straight-up invaded the country of
Grenada to overthrow its Marxist
government. Officially, President Ronald
Reagan said the invasion was to protect
American medical students, but we now
know the main goal was actually to stop
Soviet influence. The United States
installed a more American-friendly
government. Most of the world condemned
the invasion of Grenada, but most
Americans actually approved of it at the
time.
>> [music]
>> On December 20th, 1989, President George
H.W. Bush sent thousands of American
troops to overthrow and arrest Manuel
Noriega, a former CIA asset turned
drug-running dictator. Operation Just
Cause.
No, seriously, that's what the United
States called it, Operation Just Cause.
Noriega had become
a bit too defiant and was threatening
American interests near the Panama
Canal. It was a quick, somewhat massive
military operation that lasted less than
6 weeks and ended with Noriega in an
American prison. But by then, the Cold
War was winding down, bringing us to a
new era.
Operation Uphold Democracy.
>> [gasps]
>> No, seriously, the United States called
it Operation Uphold Democracy.
So cringe, bro. In 1994, President Bill
Clinton sent 25,000 troops to, quote,
convince Haitian military leaders under
the command of Joseph Raoul Cédras to
step down without a fight. In his place
returned Jean-Bertrand Aristide, who was
overthrown 3 years prior despite being
democratically elected. It was a rare
case of the United States intervening to
restore a democracy it liked. What's
also interesting about this coup was
that there is some evidence that
suggests the CIA may have helped
Aristide be overthrown the first time.
Oops. On February 29th, 2004, military
rebels overthrew Aristide from power
again, and he and others later accused
the United States for playing a role in
it. But then 9/11 happened, and
everything changed.
On September 11th, 2001, a group known
as Al-Qaeda hijacked four airplanes to
launch coordinated terrorist suicide
attacks on American soil, known as the
September 11th attacks or simply 9/11,
which I have a video about.
Duh. In response to these horrific
attacks, the United States invaded
Afghanistan to topple the Taliban regime
because they were harboring Al-Qaeda.
The United States teamed up with the
Northern Alliance, a group of Afghan
rebels, to quickly take control of the
country. This began the longest war in
American history, the war in
Afghanistan, which ended with the
Taliban returning to power in 2021.
>> [music]
>> On April 11th, 2002, rebels overthrew
Venezuela's president, Hugo Chávez.
There is some evidence that American
diplomats helped organize it. However,
the coup was short-lived. Like,
really short-lived. Chávez was back in
power within 48 hours.
>> [music]
>> On March 20th, 2003, American troops led
an invasion of Iraq to overthrow Saddam
Hussein, the country's brutal dictator.
How did the United States justify this
invasion and overthrow? Well, President
George W. Bush and his administration
had claimed Saddam had weapons of mass
destruction and ties to terrorists. No
such weapons were ever found, but
American soldiers did capture Saddam and
eventually executed him. The invasion
destabilized the entire region and led
to a long, bloody insurgency. Oh, I also
have a video about the Iraq War.
>> [music]
[bell]
>> In 2011, both American and NATO air
power helped rebels overthrow the
dictator Muammar Gaddafi. And boy, did
those rebels um
Yeah, they took care of them. Sure, the
mission was officially to quote protect
civilians, but it just quickly turned
into yet another regime change
operation. Libya fragmented into rival
governments and has basically been in
constant chaos ever since. And here's
some very recent history.
>> [music]
>> On January 3rd, 2026, American forces
carried out a military strike in
Venezuela that resulted in the capture
of Venezuela's president, Nicolas
Maduro, and his wife, Cilia Flores.
President Donald Trump announced that
the United States would oversee a new
government and it's currently holding
Maduro and Flores in prison as they
await trial for illegal drug-related
charges. So, that's it.
I think.
Oh, crap. There's another one.
Yep, literally as I was making this
video, the United States and Israel
launched strikes on Iran that killed
Supreme Leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei
and around 40 senior members of the
country's regime. Why?
Well, I don't know if we have a good
grasp as to why yet.
But that's it. That's every time the
United States overthrew a foreign
government. I think Yeah, I hope. I hope
that's every time the United States has
overthrown a foreign government.
This banana isn't that good.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Thanks Matt for letting me share a bit
of what I know with your audience and
please follow me on TikTok, Instagram,
Substack, and YouTube [music]
@chiguereroENG
if you want to see a mixture of comedy
and news. Thanks. Till next time. Thanks
for hopping in Shay for this video for
the Dominican Republican stuff. I highly
recommend you check out all his
channels. And a big inspiration for this
video was a book that I read about 20
years ago now. I can't believe it's been
that long. Overthrow by Stephen Kinzer.
It's a great book. I highly recommend
it. And look, I know that wasn't all of
them. There are more times the United
States probably was involved with
overthrowing a foreign government. I got
tired, okay? If you can think of any
more, please let us know in the
comments. Oh, and if you work for the
CIA, please let us know of any secret
ones that you were involved with in the
comments as well.
Thanks for staying curious.